and in breaking news today will smith  has been banned from the oscars and all  academy events for 10 years releasing  this statement today they apologized for  how the situation was handled on oscar  night stating we want to express our  deep gratitude to mr rock for  maintaining his composure under  extraordinary circumstances this action  we are taking today in response to will  smith's behavior is a step toward a  larger goal of protecting the safety of  our performers and guests and restoring  trust in the academy  will quickly responded to their actions  with this statement i accept and respect  the academy's decision